we're joined now by President Donald
Trump in a virtual Town Hall style event
broadcast on the US television network
Fox News President Donald Trump
predicted rapid development of a kovat
19 vaccine we are very confident we're
going to have a vaccine at the end of
the year by the end of the year have a
vaccine by the end of this we think
we're going to have a vaccine by the end
of this year and we're pushing very hard
Trump went on to claim that he was not
told till late January by US
intelligence agencies about the
spreading corona virus some reports
indicate that those agencies sounded the
alarm on January 3rd On January 23rd I
was told that there could be a virus
coming in but it was of no real import
in other words it wasn't all we got to
do something we got to do something it
was a brief conversation Trump blamed
China directly for the pandemic he
promised a report with new information
on how it originated and spread I think
they made a horrible mistake
and they didn't want to admit it more
than 68,000 people in the US have died
from kovat 19 and the numbers are rising
Trump said the toll could reach 90,000 a
higher number than he has cited before
many public health experts are warning
against premature lifting of stay at
home orders saying that could lead to a
new surge in infections without giving
any specific dates Trump said the u.s.
needed to restart its economy soon we
can't stay close as a country we're not
going to have a country left the
president ducked a question about
safeguarding vulnerable nursing home
residents and called White House
reporters questions horrible it is
widely considered that the presidential
election in November will be a
referendum on Trump's handling of the
pandemic Rob Reynolds al-jazeera